um
so um
a follow-up a follow-up to the remember
that kid that was crying because he
didn't get his nerf gun
sorry bucko no i'm kidding um
i mean honestly like you you cried like
that in my family when you were a kid in
front of santa the amount of wealth
you'd have on your body that night
unbelievable you're gonna embarrass me
in front of santa claus
uh this is uh this that maul fired that
santa
and uh they got a different santa to
deliver a nerf gun wait a minute roy so
that doesn't make any sense there's only
one santa
oh no mike the santa's at the malls are
helpers they're santa's helpers
the malls actually got the real santa to
come from north pole to do this
oh no no mike no no mike no they're the
real senator they're the real senator
they're the real
[Laughter]
it's a home invasion it's a real gun
it's not a nerf gun
it's the new york state police ma'am i'm
sorry we've got a warrant to stick a gun
in your
apparently people here
[Laughter]
this poor kid's having the worst week
ever
he's gonna grow up to hate christmas
michael come here
there's someone at the door can you go
get the door
mom is it gonna be stephen crowder again
he scared me
mom i already saw the camera outside
setting up so i know what's happening
this is really weird can we pick like i
don't know
a less mundane song to play i mean this
is kind of stereotyped
can you play the run dmc christmas song
mom i'm more of a herb albert christmas
guy
we get that up on the on the old herb
albert
open the door he has a banging christmas
album
uh it's no michael buble but okay it's
pretty banging the my yo i'm telling you
don't sleep on the herb albert christmas
album
oh this doesn't make any sense because i
talked to the other sand and hit a
walter a walter gun on his desk
and he kept owning the lip tarts i
santa's different than the other santa
yeah santa was more fun
the door open the door i like the santa
more he spent more money on christmas
presents for me than he pays his
employees
yay he made me send an nda which was
weird
[Laughter]
who the [ __ ] are you it was a mistake
made yesterday
well we're so sorry we're sorry about
that santa claus at the mall
you know those people
you know i had to kick out 109 elfs from
my workshop
i'll tell you what you wouldn't have
that problem if you'd asked for
chocolate coins okay
if he opened that bear and it was a
[ __ ] ar-15
or a [ __ ] ksg just like what the [ __ ]
whoa we wanted to make it up to you
this kid's gonna have the best life ever
have you heard of and remember kid don't
take any [ __ ] at school
you own tea now
somebody pointed out that crowder's
favorite reindeer is prancer
i heard about this north pole
and i rushed down
i mean i know what you see i parked that
size of subaru i couldn't bring my um
reindeer yeah sorry uh my my reindeers
are resting for
christmas eve and the slays in the shop
so i've got my uh my saturn out there
hey at least it's red kid by the way how
many [ __ ] nerf guns is this kid gonna
get now you know too many jesus
christmas
like now he's gonna be like can i get
something else gonna get cyberpunk can
you get a ps5
something i mean i could trade all these
nerf guns in and maybe get a ps5 at this
point
and the next person that knocks on the
door is gonna be keemstar and he's gonna
be like
hey kid i got you a ps5 psych
like what a dick
um that looks like a nerf assault rifle
and i'm really bothered by it like
there's literally no reason for a kid
that age to own a nerf gun that large
unless he's
trying to lightly tap everyone in a mall
jb's got a good point if he did get it
could use that to get a ps5 sure so she
just [ __ ] get whatever you want kid
watch now this this santa's gonna suck
too he's also going to be
hyper-political but on the other side
now listen kid don't show that to the
democrats or the atf they're going to
charge you 200
all right listen to me if the atf comes
you lost it in a boating accident come
on rehearse it with me kid you lost it
in a boating i want to hear you say it
okay okay trust the plan ron swanson
santa
and remember kid you're legally allowed
technically in most jurisdictions to
booby-trap your front door
dudes come on man this kid's had enough
this year he just let him just be santa
okay
all right michael santa's probably
really busy
trust me this gang got [ __ ] he's got to
do
san ain't got [ __ ] he's got to do
actually i was going to go down to the
old uh
cracker barrel and cry for about an hour
oh man